ce qu'isabelle prend des photos d'elle
toute nue pour ses études de dessin sur
des nues par une non non tout fou tout
nu oui je vais pas demander à kelly ou à
la gamme de se mettre tout nu tout le
monde gagnerait je le sais mais met donc
du coup pour faire des études de dessin
de nu bah oui je prends je prends
quelques photos que j'efface
réapprennent à west aus vous avez plein
de photos devenues c'est on a ri j'ai vu
une photo non alors je ne demande pas il
les rate tout
ah oui c'est qui alors moi c'est vous je
suis une chance elle sur la photo dans
le rétroviseur dans la glace ça va je me
vois pas dans le rétroviseur dans les
glaces venu dans les contenus qui prend
des photos d'elle toute nue kim bien se
prendre en photo tout nu à moi j'aime
bien me balader tout nu chez lui
quoiqu'elle iv novelli castaldi bas même
si ce bateau ce qui m'a donné mais j'ai
déménagé pour ça en fait que j'habitais
à paris la whey pas que pour ça mais
pour être libre chez soi en fait je
trouve ça horrible de pas pouvoir
quand tu es mal avec le bonnet je vais
toujours nue avec le bonnet faire je
bats toi vite adam toi tu es très
pudique utah des enfants mais sait même
pas ce que j'aime pas je me sens pas
j'aime pas me voir mieux en fait
ah ouais et toi naulleau toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
azumi au dessus du toit
non non jamais même dans la douche tu
mets quoi tu mets un nom
d'abord j'ai deux chantiers pas preneur
prend juste il commence à gedo chasser
pas prise on croit que toshiba sa
tronche chatons quoi se laisser vaincre
ou non mais sérieux quoi c'est vrai mais
pas brighi khaldi moi j'ai tellement été
nu dans ma vie que maintenant je préfère
être ludique puisque elle était
mannequin et c'est vrai que vous faisiez
beaucoup d'occasions il rappelé à quoi
c'est un peu nul mais enfin ça me
dérangeait pas aussi chez tellement
défiler nu que j'en ai c'est bon quoi
j'en ai ras le bol chez vous vous seriez
chez moi je suis nue je suis chez nous
alors je vous dire moi je me mettrais
venu pour pas vexer les autres vraiment
le meilleur moment à las vegas massa
restera mais jusqu'à la fin de mes
jouets comme vous êtes
il a été enfermé en dehors de sa chambre
et donc on est obligé de traverser tout
le pen un petit slip aller chercher les
clés l'accueil est souple et bonnes
femmes tout le monde le regarde et
passait mais comme un ovni
j'ai adoré leur regard et s'est marié 40
ans tu annonçant le meilleur moment de
ta vie ses côtés
[Applaudissements]